Ranger Holter felt the bark of the tree trunk
slamming into his back, practically knocking
all the air out of his lungs as he tried desperately
to slow his frantic breathing.
The sound of his own panting filled him with
a sudden horrifying thought: if he could hear
his own ragged breaths, then it could hear
them too.
He clamped a hand over his mouth, clenching
his jaw shut so tightly that he thought his
teeth might splinter as he pushed them together.
His free hand gripped the tranquilizer gun,
shuddering as the snap of a twig rang out
somewhere behind him.
It had caught up to him already.
He could bolt, make a quick dash for cover
behind another tree, but it was close enough
now that it would see him.
And if it did, it would come rushing after
him with a speed that even a seasoned Park
Ranger couldn’t match.
As much as he tried to force himself to stay
still, the petrified curiosity got the better
of him.
Holter peeked out from behind the tree, and
immediately wished he hadn’t.
It had all started out as what sounded like
an everyday occurrence.
High atop his watchtower in the Glacier National
Park, Ranger Holter had been enjoying the
view of Montana’s Rocky Mountains, a cup
of coffee from his thermos in his hand.
Then the familiar squawk of his radio had
cut short his appreciation of the serene,
peaceful scenery.
Holter sighed, tossing the remaining contents
of the cup over the tower’s railing, wondering
what kind of day he was in for as he went
to answer the radio.
Most of the time, things in Glacier Park were
as peaceful as they looked.
But the Park Ranger knew that staying vigilant
could make all the difference when it came
to finding a missing hiker in time, or the
difference between deterring a group of campers
away from a family of bears and having a hell
of a mess to clean up.
He pushed down on the button of the speaker
microphone, connected to the bulky radio that
took up practically an entire desk.
“Holter, thank god!”
came the relieved voice from the other side.
“We’ve been trying to reach everyone,
put them on alert!
We’ve got trouble, reports of a coyote gone
feral attacking folks!”
“I’m on it,” Holter replied, grabbing
his gear from the cramped watchtower as he
continued to speak into the mic.
“Where did the report come in from?”
“Not far from your station, I’d say about
a klick west from your position.”
Stowing his tranquilizer gun, Ranger Holder
descended the ladder from his watchtower down
to ground level.
As a Park Ranger, Holder valued the environment
he worked in and As a fan of the SCP universe,
we know how much you value intricate world-building,
or in some cases, world destroying.
But either way, we couldn’t be happier to
introduce you to the sponsor of today’s
video - WorldAnvil.
WorldAnvil is a comprehensive set of world-building
tools that not only help you craft and organize
your unique setting but also present it in
a captivating manner.
From wiki-like articles and interactive maps
to a full-fledged RPG Campaign Manager and
novel-writing software, WorldAnvil has everything
a world creator could dream of.
WorldAnvil equips you with over 25 templates,
prompting you to dive deeper into your creations.
Enrich your content by embedding maps, images,
sound effects, and even little secrets for
that immersive touch.
With their innovative design, you can easily
visualize your world through maps, chronicle
its history with timelines, and fine-tune
events with intricate details.
Your crafted world can be beautifully showcased
on a unique homepage, inviting others to dive
into your vision.
Got a sudden idea while working on another?
No problem!
WorldAnvil lets you swiftly create new articles
or link existing ones, ensuring you never
lose track of your inspiration.
But my personal favorite feature is their
interactive maps!
Beyond just creating and uploading your own
designs, you can directly link your creations,
allowing for a dynamic and engaging experience.
And, if you're collaborating, invite your
team to refine, write, and even let your fans
chip in.
I’m currently working on my own interactive
map of Site 17 and maybe I’ll even let you
see it when I’m done.
But don’t wait for me.
Dive into WorldAnvil yourself and elevate
your world-building game!
And here's a treat: use our link in the description
to go to WorldAnvil.com and use the code SCP
to grab a whopping 51% OFF any yearly subscription.
Explore, create, and share with WorldAnvil!
The sun was already starting to dip out of
sight behind the trees; pretty soon, it’d
be pitch black, save for the beam of his flashlight.
He had to move fast; coyotes were only known
to attack humans on rare occasions, usually
they kept away, at least enough to make them
a minimal risk.
But waiting for him just west of the watchtower
wasn’t a coyote.
At least, not at first.
Watching it from behind the tree moments later,
Ranger Holter’s stomach turned at the sight
of the creature.
It walked bipedally, like a human, but the
shape was all wrong.
Its legs looked broken, but that hadn’t
stopped it from catching up.
Instead of bending at the knee, they were
Z-shaped, pointing back behind the creature,
then twisting back again in the opposite direction
at the joint.
They looked more like the legs of a dog, but
they were far too big.
The same could be said of its arms, bent out
of shape at multiple points like its legs
were.
The creature was a mess of misshapen limbs.
The cartilage in its ears had seemingly reformed
into points, and there were claws protruding
from its fingertips, practically bursting
out from where a human’s fingernails would
be.
But beneath it all, and what alarmed Ranger
Holter the most, was its skin.
It had darkened in patches, layers of fur
sprouting over those areas.
But there were still parts that remained clear,
where skin – human skin – was still visible,
peeling away to reveal the new, fur-coated
layer underneath.
It looked like a grotesque accident, like
something ripped straight out of an old horror
movie, the kind of monster that a mad scientist
would make by haphazardly splicing DNA and
playing God.
Holter checked the tranquilizer gun in his
trembling fingers, still empty after that
most recent shot.
He reached for another dart, slowly sliding
it into the loading mechanism and readying
the pistol.
It cocked… and made a sound.
The creature’s malformed head turned, snapping
directly towards the source of the noise – directly
towards Holter.
He turned to sprint away, trying to expand
the distance between him and it; if he was
too close, the dart wouldn’t have enough
momentum when he pulled the trigger.
The toe of his boot snagged on something solid,
unmoving, a root from the tree he’d been
hiding behind.
He felt himself tumble, landing with a hard
thud against the forest floor.
His gun, it had fallen from his grasp.
He scrabbled around in the dirt for it, barely
able to see where the tranquilizer had landed
in the dark.
Just as his fingertips brushed past something
metal, Holter felt the force of something
heavy strike his back again.
This time though, it wasn’t a tree… it
was the creature.
It snarled, gnashing its canid jaws that were
protruding out from its skull, rows of sharp
teeth that had uprooted the old ones burying
themselves into the Park Ranger’s neck and
not letting go… until he’d stopped moving
for good.
A few short hours later, a convoy of mysterious,
unmarked vehicles arrived at Glacier National
Park.
The rest of the Park Rangers who had reported
the strange activity were approached by shadowy
figures who refused to give their names, or
offer up any form of identification other
than just referring to themselves as ‘the
experts in things like this’.
Not long after, none of the others would remember
Ranger Holter, or the incident that had led
to his untimely death.
After administering amnestics, it didn’t
take SCP Foundation search party long to discover
a lone coyote, sniffing around the remains
of a Park Ranger, covered in blood.
The wild animal was captured, to be brought
back for testing before being re-released
into the wild.
Meanwhile, the Foundation scoured the rest
of the area until they came across the real
culprit.
Standing in a clearing a short distance from
a footpath through the forest was SCP-1579.
Of course, the next challenge was getting
it packed up and transported to Bio Site 66…
without touching it.
To the untrained eye, SCP-1579 looks to be
fairly unassuming, even as far as anomalous
objects go.
It is simply an old, wooden sculpture, the
kind that can even occasionally be found in
various wooded areas throughout the world.
Its age is apparent from even one cursory
glance at SCP-1579, the partial damage to
its cedar surface speaking to the numerous
years it has existed for, along with the bright
green moss that covers it.
Although, curiously, this moss doesn’t seem
to dry out and die in response to changes
in humidity, nor does it affect SCP-1579’s
structural integrity.
As for where it came from, and who made it,
those are still unknown.
As if the answer to what holds SCP-1579’s
anomalous properties, whether or not the cedar
it was carved from or the moss coating the
sculpture possesses some unknown properties,
or if SCP-1579 was somehow imbued with these
after being created.
Initial testing by the SCP Foundation’s
researchers determined SCP-1579 to have an
abnormally high resistance to the type of
damage wood – and particularly cedar wood
– is susceptible to.
For one, it does not seem to show any signs
of rotting or natural degradation.
For another, it is also resistant to heat
– at least, to a certain extent.
It doesn’t burn the same way other objects
constructed from cedar would, however, this
sculpture is not entirely indestructible.
Pieces can easily be chipped off of the main
body of SCP-1579, and these splintered fragments
continue to carry the same anomalous effects
as the rest of the sculpture, even when separate
from it.
But, of course, you want to know about the
creature.
How does this supposedly harmless – if a
little structurally abnormal – cedar wood
sculpture connects to whatever it was that
killed Park Ranger Holter?
Well, it’s quite simple actually: SCP-1579
killed Holter.
Not directly, you understand, but by proxy
through its further anomalous properties.
Still confused?
Well then, how about a demonstration?
Let’s take one of the Foundation’s preferred
test subjects, an expendable member of D Class
personnel, probably spending multiple life
sentences working for the SCP Foundation than
behind the bars of a maximum security institution.
Now, what would happen if you placed this
delightful individual in the same room as
SCP-1579?
Well, nothing initially.
That is, until the subject touches the cedar
wood surface of the sculpture, either out
of curiosity or following the instructions
of a Foundation researcher.
That’s when the real anomaly starts.
The wooden sculpture will exhibit a slight,
but observable movement, shuddering slightly
as if moved by an unseen force.
This will precede the person who touched the
object feeling a burning sensation, that kind
of irritating, painful heat that spreads underneath
the surface of the skin.
The burning will always begin at the area
of their body that made direct contact with
SCP-1579, and touching it again at any point
will trigger a reactivation of the sculpture’s
anomalous effects.
Subjects experiencing the effects of SCP-1579
have described the feeling as being akin to
a bad case of sunburn that rapidly spreads
across the skin from the point of contact,
only to stop once it has affected a person’s
entire body.
Following the subsidence of the burning sensation,
subjects experiencing the side effects of
touching SCP-1579 will notice an immediate
change to their skin.
Within a window of three minutes, their skin
becomes thin and paper-like in its texture,
before starting to peel away.
Once this stage occurs, the peeling skin will
reveal a new layer underneath, hence the colloquially
used codename for this anomaly: ‘Different
Skin.’
However, this so-called different skin isn’t
merely a new layer of otherwise ordinary human
skin.
Instead, it will belong to another species
entirely.
A person coming into contact with SCP-1579
will find themselves rapidly developing new
skin that shares the physical traits – as
well as matching DNA – to that of a number
of animal species.
It should be noted that these features will
continue to rapidly develop until the subject
is entirely transformed and is no longer considered
to qualify as a human being.
As for the specific transformation that occurs,
there are a number of known outcomes that
repeat in the following cycle.
Let’s say our Class D from earlier – we’ll
call them Subject A – touched SCP-1579 at
the start of the cycle.
They would, after the burning sensation stops
and peeling begins, start to sprout dark feathers
across their torso, arms and upper legs, likely
with a great deal of pain as the sharp quill
of these feathers start to burst out from
beneath the skin.
Beneath the knees, Subject A will see their
legs start to become yellow and scaly, as
well as a change that causes their toenails
to similarly start to painfully protrude outwards
until they form pointed, blackened talons.
Subject A’s face will also start to grow
feathers; however, these grow outwards away
from the areas of the nose and mouth.
Flight feathers will also protrude from the
forearms, multiplying in number until their
entire body is covered.
At which point, Subject A, on every level
including genetically, more closely resembles
a Corvus corax, more commonly known as the
common raven, than a human being anymore.
Take another test subject, Subject B, and
get them to touch SCP-1579 right after.
Their different skin is covered in brown fur,
that’s approximately four inches long.
Their lips and skin underneath the fur will
darken, and their nose will become constantly
moist.
Claws will start to grow from their fingertips,
although these will be notably smaller than
those of a fully grown creature of the same
species: an Ursus arctos horribilis, or a
grizzly bear.
Then we get to the point in the cycle where
some unwitting hiker encountered SCP-1579
in the forests of Glacier National Park, Montana.
When this subject, Subject C, touched the
cedar sculpture, their skin began to grow
layered fur, as the cartilage of their ears
is separated from their tissue and replaced
by new, reshaped cartilage.
Much like Subject B, who SCP-1579 turned into
a bear, Subject C also had darkened skin,
a moistened nose, and longer, sharper nails.
It was at some point during this transformation
that an unassuming Park Ranger stumbled upon
Subject C. Frightened by what he saw, this
Ranger was unable to identify that what he
interpreted as attacks by some kind of half-human,
half-animal hybrid, were actually desperate
pleas for help AS Subject C was transformed
into a coyote.
Although it's hard to say which physiological
change triggered by SCP-1579 is the most alarming
or unpleasant to experience, the fourth kind
is in no way any more pleasant than the preceding
three in the cycle.
Subject D of this particular series of tests
will find the new layer of skin that emerges
under the old to be hairless, and of a green
coloration, often with brown markings.
Unlike the previous instances, their skin
will rapidly begin to dry out, and seems to
be far more reactive to the humidity of the
surrounding environment.
It is also far thinner than that of the skin
possessed by other transformations that SCP-1579
causes.
So thin, in fact, that the eyeballs of Subject
D will be visible through its eyelids, which
rapidly become translucent, similar to those
of the Pseudacris regilla, otherwise known
as the Pacific tree frog.
Repeated activation of SCP-1579’s anomalous
properties will trigger the next transformation
in the cycle, whether the cedar wood sculpture
is touched by a new subject, or repeatedly
by the same person.
In the latter instance, where a subject is
re-exposed to SCP-1579, the additional changes
their body undergoes will be significantly
more painful.
Their already newly-replaced outer layer of
skin will fail to dry out, and will begin
bleeding instead.
Three or four consecutive exposures to SCP-1579
will lead to excessive bodily trauma for the
subject, usually causing them to die from
shock before the fourth transformation is
complete.
And, as we’re sure you can imagine, an amalgamation
of a human, a raven, a grizzly bear, a coyote,
and a tree frog is hardly a pleasant sight.
This unfortunate fate was suffered during
one of the first incidents with SCP-1579 that
brought the Foundation’s attention to it.
During an elementary school field trip, a
teacher who was explaining the history of
totem poles in Native American culture accidentally
touched SCP-1579.
While experiencing the pain of her transformation,
she fell against the sculpture in a panic,
not realizing it had been what caused her
to change.
This repeated triggering of the object's anomalous
effects led to her untimely death, an event
that had to be wiped from the minds of her
students by the Foundation, using the careful
application of Class B amnestics.
For now, SCP-1579 is kept in a secure, sterile
environment at a Foundation storage warehouse,
where personnel are not permitted to make
any contact with it.
So, there’s no need to worry about accidentally
running into SCP-1579 in the wild.
Although, there are always plenty of other
things to worry about while out on a hike
through the forest…
things that could be right behind you…
Now check out “SCP-173 - THE SCULPTURE”
and “SCP-1897 - HUMAN DOMESTICATION SOCIETY”
for more!